[Music]
three fire so free fire is ultimately a
shoot-'em-up movie in the vein of
something Tarantino would have done in
this earlier years like in the 90s or
Guy Ritchie in the early 2000s one is
there is an arms deal that's going down
and then a scuffle starts in a shootout
starts and now is this arms deal becomes
two sides that are shooting at each
other for a while in this movies like oz
is a great intro for a movie how long is
this going to go on then I checked my
watch I was like oh we've been at it for
like a half an hour it's just the way
it's gonna be this is the movie and it
is the movies pretty much so but you
need to know but I really enjoyed it
ahead a hell of a time in the movie the
movie has a great cast man Armie Hammer
was good Armie Hammer is good man the
stigma of The Lone Ranger can wash off
over time I think ompletely has it dude
has charisma and a very sarcastic dry
sense of humor which is completely in
play in his moment in play and in place
because movie really does revolve around
that Rives on that show there's a thing
about the movie the movie as I said you
know something that Tarantino would have
done or Guy Ritchie by implication the
movie has sarcastic wit it's funny it's
humorous there's more than a few times
really all bullets are flying but it's
also you're laughing and chuckling
you're at least chuckling there was
never a gut-busting moment like morbid
or otherwise I like Marvin ever got shot
in the face in Pulp Fiction where your
look your dying laughing you're like I'm
a sick human being nothing like that
happens in the movie but the movie does
have humor I was actually very amazed
the movie that starts out in the
warehouse and ends in a warehouse can
keep me that entertained for that long
yes it does hit it down time every
shootout movie does and yet I really had
a smile on my face for the majority of
this thing and it doesn't have the
flashback or intrigue like Reservoir
Dogs did really oh you're going back
getting more story everything you know
about these characters you know because
they're in a firefight which is a great
way to showcase someone's personality
you want to know who someone is yeah put
them in a trench
have bullets fly at them you'll know
this movie does play up the element well
could have gone for a little more but it
is what it is that's not the movie this
is and there's no real shock ending for
the movie there's a wrap-up and an
ending to a movie that's supposed to
make you go like ooh that's how it went
down but you see it coming a mile away
not like Tim Roth was the cop or some
it is not I could like these simple
premise movies give the simplest and
shortest reviews but really what is
there to say about free fire movie
wasn't
label the characters were great there
was some camaraderie and banter among
all of them sometimes it was friendly
sometimes it was venomous bullets were
flying out people snarky ass remarks
were flying that people people got shot
people died I chuckled most of time and
in the end free fire was a good time no
alcohol required probably would be
better with alcohol though if you're
like if you have your friends over like
dudes let's watch free fire have a few
drinks that's a good time right guys so
free fire have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite
sugar mobster comedy ish movie that's
not Pulp Fiction or snacks can string
and Nic right there you got to pick
another one but let's just make it fun
so whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]